herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich kann es nicht abwarten
loszulegen ich habe mir nämlich nur für
dieses video teilweise vom anderen ende
der welt 3q zu bestellen die werden
heute auf festen und ich bin wirklich
gespannt ob wir halten was sie
versprechen weil es sind gute sachen
dabei so als nummer 1 ist eine relativ
praktische sache zumindest wenn es
funktioniert und ich glaube jeder von
euch kennt das problem man trinkt cola
beziehungsweise irgendwas offener dose
und trinke ich mit lehrerin jüngeren
mann durfte es nicht leer trinken weil
es zu viel verkehr sogar so da haben
sich leute gedacht wir haben die lösung
dafür und zwar genau dieses teil ihr mit
dass sie ziemlich genau aus wie eine
plastikflasche wie einfach oben
abgeschnitten wurde
hat schon jemand eine waffe leihen
könnte er klopft acht euro gekostet wir
also dass es einfach wieder weg hier mal
keinen aufschrauben und wieder zu
schrauben es wirkt ein bisschen billig
deshalb bin ich gespannt ob das
überhaupt funktionieren wird
ich hole jetzt erst mal eine dose leider
keine dr pepper auch aber es gab eine
tochterfirma in den usa große probleme
die wir für diese diktatoren gemacht
also wenn man so was wie eine red bull
dose oder diese länglichen coladosen hat
dann wird das ganze leider nicht
funktionieren aber ja ich würde sagen
wir öffnen erst mal die cola dafür schon
mal schafft ohne ihr das ganze
wohnzimmer mutter cola zu setzen jetzt
kann man im prinzip irgendwie den deckel
drauf drücken oder sowas scheint er zu
passen
ok also der becken sitzt jetzt
bombenfest wie wird vielleicht ich kann
doch einfach wären festhalten jetzt
kommt die große frage
erstmals können wir da ganz normal zeugt
von ausschütten
ok-chef funktioniert wird man angenommen
ich bin nur ein bisschen cola trinken
hat suche ohne dass mir zu süß muss
leider auch wenn kurz
und jetzt verschließen wieder zeit hier
wieder warum den deckel drauf und
probieren mal wie sich das ganze verhält
sollte denn es wird wieder drauf und ich
mache den test bereit dafür
base kopfüber stelle da nicht mehr
auslaufen wenn das land so richtig
funktioniert ok scheint zu funktionieren
denn schütteln oder lieber nicht
die schweren bisschen auf jeden fall
aber kommt nicht ein stück entfernt ist
nein es ist gerade nicht passiert nein
ich bin übrigens gleich wieder leute das
war das gucke ich meine mich an mein
gott und cola und ich habe noch witze
darüber gemacht läuft momentan einfach
ich nicht gesagt
ricky fester auf diese weise ein
bisschen über hat sich ja gezeigt dass
ich über mögliche muss ich nicht sagen
und auch wenn auch mit der grund sein
warum das nicht in deutschland verkauft
wird weil die kurse bleibt drin
anscheinend auch ein ziemlicher druck
aufgebaut das vielleicht nicht machen
und gibt einfach menschen die zu dumm
nur für uns gemacht machen
in ersten über alkohol also was sind
meine gedanken zu diesem teil hier
erstmal bin ich ziemlich wütend auch das
ding eigentlich hat das getan was es
verspricht also das behält die
kohlensäure drin wenn du die dose auch
wenn du ein allerdings dumm bist und das
den kopf über hält
[Musik]
comic nummer zwei dieses teil hier habe
ich vor 20 tagen aus china bestellt und
zwar ist das in dieser komischen boxerin
mit euch vorstellen dass ist die box in
der die dinger verkauft werden wege
wieder fit designt ist also das kommt
lebt und forscht er war in meinen augen
europäischen maßstäben dass so was in
dem geschäft landet ihr körper
vielleicht auf den bildern auch schon
gesehen was es ist es ist so ein cola
spender eigentlich ich baue jetzt
erstmal auf so können wir in diese
ganzen einzelteile einmal so eine art
fan ein raise merkel dieses ding hier
und wie funktioniert wird also dachteil
packt man hier auch dann hat man quasi
so ein ständer und hier hat man den
fahrplan wie man auch daran geschraubt
ja also die überlegung ist mannschaft
hier oben drauf eine colaflasche und
dann kann man mit dem fahrrad fahren
hier ich probiert jetzt einfach mal aus
und zwar als erstes mit der ganz kleinen
klasse wobei den decken fast ein
bisschen groß aussieht muss ich sagen
okay
überschäumend schon genug oder hierbei
und du bist scheint zu funktionieren
ja also es wird fühlt sich ziemlich fest
ich habe einfach übertrieben schiss dass
ich jetzt gerade für alles verkackt also
wie geht das auch dass zu große frage
das sollte jetzt gleich wie von selbst
sozusagen aus der flasche rauslaufen ist
es fertig drehte es einfach nur um
ich habe ihm vermutlich schon wieder
fahre merkte ich mache welche videos
nicht auf bekannte aber gerne öfters
machen
lustig dass sich die attacke dabei ihr
sowas eppler sehen wollten wir gerne mal
leichter durch hab gerade vergessen
dieses rote bändchen herab zu machen und
dadurch teilweise luft rein
beziehungsweise kohle raus da schneidet
jetzt erstmal ab und schreiben es aber
noch nach vorne dran
also ich hoffe glück ich hoffe wirklich
dass man wirklich dass nicht die
wartezeit gelohnt hat wie gesagt 20 tage
nur für dieses eine links und jetzt
probieren prämiert noch mal um
merck wird immer noch kohle raus bin ich
eigentlich komplett verblödet und wenn
wir den fanfaren aus machen will bekommt
was raus dadurch kommt kohle raus leute
abgesehen
und genauso leute flugschiff mir euer
fahren
das läuft hier an die seite rauf
konstruktive großartig drückt einfach
nur hin und wasserbau ins glas wein dann
hört mir auch zu drücken und es kommt
viel mehr leute in afrika ab ich habe
genug rund 40 minuten
ich würde sagen ich räume das alles mal
auf ich will nicht sofort ein vielleicht
mag der finanzwelt ich probiere
vielleicht nochmal auf nicht der ganz
große flasche ein bisschen angst aber
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
der einzige mensch bin der so tun ist
ich kann mein gesamtes wohnzimmer einmal
in die waschmaschine stecken danach als
er ohne spaß leute hoffentlich gefällt
euch das video einfach rührend below das
geld die zeit und alles was schicken wir
haben in dieses loch video wird noch mal
ausprobieren
wir nehmen die risiken ein
rotes bändchen ist ab jetzt schrauben
wir das so fest wie wir verdammt noch
mal nur können damit das teil niemals
wieder zurückgeht
die leute also man höre ich habe so
angst was jetzt mein komplettes leben
hier kaputt geht
ich könnte jetzt natürlich eine spüle
wien und der arbeiter drehen aber sollte
daraufhin zog es dir so festgeschraubt
wirklich hin bekommen also da geht gar
nichts mehr
wir machen jetzt das pendel wieder drauf
probieren sie mal umzudrehen also bleibt
unbedingt auch dran zu zum dritten geld
weil keine ahnung vielleicht explodiert
dann hier auch alles einfach
also ich spüre etwas flüssigkeit einmal
ist es stets am 1
das ist ja was wäre okay leute irgendwo
laut kohler aus japan eröffnet in den
haaren jetzt mal da kommt auch ihre
ausdauer normal funktioniert und wie ok
erfolg kommt mit übertriebenem druck
raus weil es keinen sinn macht weil dann
hat man halt ab oder und sprudel
letztendlich der erfolg kommt mit jeder
menge puder raus ich probier's mal auch
noch nach cola schmeckt oder nach
plastik nach cola aber es hat überhaupt
kein problem mehr
ich habe jetzt eine erklärung vielleicht
wofür diese dieser teaser dabei ist und
sagte ich mir vorstellen dass man
unbedingt extremen über druck
auszugleichen einfach oben ein paar
löcher entwickeln kann
ich mache das jetzt einfach wäre
skaliert auch alles okay leute das
könnte die idee sein junger mann ist
klar dass wir nicht alles vermischt wird
wer in den text machen jetzt hab ich mal
ganz langsam ein bisschen kohle ab
langsam ist nicht kommt ziemlich viel
druck drauf und ich denke mal das wird
bedeuten dass das volk nicht mehr so
sprudeln wie normal
nee also es hat einfach nicht mehr so
viel spiele wie es eigentlich haben
sollen mehrere kohle diesem tag der
umstand damit würdigten kongresses nötig
und wir schreiten voran zur nächsten
sache so leute die nächste und letzte
sache ist tatsächlich alle die positiven
bewertungen und auch in deutschland
verfügbar ist und war ein flash maker ja
was das ist ich habe absolut keine
ahnung der packungsinhalt von dem
zeitpunkt ein äußeres teil ein inneres
und ein löffel so man sollte das innere
teilen das äußere zogen das habe ich
übernachten der gefriertruhe gehabt dann
die flüssigkeit rein schütten und alle
paar minuten umrühren also den rand weg
craften sozusagen dafür öffne ich jetzt
mal eine weitere cola flasche und
schönere einfachen müssen noch rein
mit ein bisschen auf meine ich so viel
sage ich mal
jetzt muss ich das alle 60 sekunden
umrühren time auf 60 sekunden
ok also dass wir bringen es das
allererste mal um
[Musik]
es hat nichts gebracht und die kohle als
nicht mehr wirklichkeit verpflichtet not
affiche schmiden peric der
konzernabschluss stücke - work well in
den shaker und unlock recommended
dies hat man schreibt ernst ich mach das
allererste mal ein gadget ein live video
und ich freier bei jedem von mir drei
männern sowohl abfischen auch was er für
bing explodiert mein ganzes wohnzimmer
zweite ding nimmt die kohlensäure aus
der kohle an macht dann kommt über
geschmäcker kohl aber es hat überhaupt
keinen alkohol mehr und dieses ding kann
oder scheint an scheinen zu
funktionieren weil ich mit cola
ich habe bei amazon nach kohlers gesucht
und zerfalle ersten treffer das heißt
die suchmaschinenoptimierung ist darauf
ausgelegt dass ich das hier
funktionieren egal ob hier und warte
dass irgendwas passiert sollte ich habe
jetzt gerade eine ewigkeit gechillt und
vielleicht merkt ihr das tor noch genau
flüssig wieder voller essen nichts mit
klasse
ich lasse mir von mal genauere
viertelstunde stehen was wir jetzt
gerade ewig drinnen nicht mehr angezogen
weil ich einfach voll gefahren nach dem
video so was passiert wenn ich hier mit
dem dreh nicht dass kein bisschen äußere
sonntags gebildet wenn ich das hier mehr
rausnehmen
was rein schütte hier kein fleisch
lokaler geht's nicht seite 8 seht ihr
das hier das ist in meinen augen ganz
klar flach dass ich hier sehe und das
werde ich jetzt essen wir haben diesen
einen löffel fleisch als nach einer
halben stunde warten probierte ich
möchte lecker schmeckt wirklich lecker
pines von den kohle hätte ich heute
gekauft habe und für mehr farbe ins
sinnvoll
die sind alles für ein arschloch mekka
toll für andere sachen aber ich wollte
halt eine cola das video durch trotzdem
unterhalten und falls das getan hat
bitte um mich zu trösten schickt das
video einen freund und tötet den
like-button einfach weil dafür die welt
der gadgets wäre so einfach und cool und
planen frachtgut leute gesehen von
diesmal wieder hinwies